here now with reaction retired army
lieutenant general Fox News contributor
Keith Kellogg General Kellogg it's a
pleasure to have you and I want to start
off the bat with peace through strength
that's what we had with Trump now we
have violence through weakness you
shared with me a riveting account of a
time when President Trump got a 3:00 a
phone call can you share that with our
viewers yeah Kaylee thanks for having me
well that was when the American Embassy
uh in Baghdad was under siege in attack
and the the embassy was actually burning
documents uh which means your embassy's
about ready to get overrun and that was
right after there was a strike that
killed an American we responded with
f-15s pretty heavy hit they attacked the
embassy and we woke the president and
the vice president up and I was on the
phone with Robert O'Brien we were
actually talking together The Situation
Room and both called us pretty early in
the morning and I was talking to Robert
and I said Robert you we need to wake
the president and I'll wake the vice
president so I we picked up the phone
and we called the president and the vice
president simultaneously and put him on
the speaker and we said you know our
embassy's under attack uh and and what
you know this is who's behind it we said
the Iranian proxy forces and Iraq are
behind it and the president said well
who is actually driving this and we said
the cuds force led by solomani he said
let's get solomani so within two days of
of us striking and them striking an
American position in herbal killing a
contractor which we responded to two
days later they attacked the Embassy 3
days later we killed solomani uh and it
was it was we set up a a a policy of
what we called escalation and putting uh
your opponent at risk well the really
the interesting thing behind that Kaylee
the story was we we reached out this we
reached out through the Swiss because
they were our emissaries to the Iranians
because we had no contact with them
diplomatic contact with them there are
What's called the protecting power and
we told the Iranians very clearly if you
resp respond to us after we killed
solomani we are going to kill this the
supreme leader Kini wow and nothing
really happened after that attack they
attacked allad Airbase nothing really
happened but here's the tell and it was
the interesting one we knew we we'
actually achieved our goal people don't
realize this but s days after that
attack the Iranians shot down a
Ukrainian airliner leaving ton uh
airport and through intercepts we
realized that they thought it was us
coming to get commen
that's when we said within a 10-day
period of of strikes and counter strikes
that they had said okay the Americans
are really serious let's back off and
then it went dead quiet for the next
year with Iran they just not want to
mess with us because we put something at
risk that they didn't want to have put
at risk and that was their leadership
and we said we're coming for you if you
attack and kill another American and not
another American was killed in the next
year they knew president Trump meant
business and therefore American lives
were saved I mean I just can't that that
story is so amazing to me because you
have this 48 hour window president Trump
the administration takes action takes
out solomani we've had attacks on
American forces in in Iraq and in Syria
four weeks and there's a pinp pick
strike pin strike in the the desert of
Syria and then Iran's back to business
today through their proxies attacking
Americans what should be done right
now well we what we need to do is the
thought process ought to be that there's
a thing called an escalation ladder and
you go up this escalation ladder and
they're doing tit fortat you know a
little bit here a little bit there you
need to put something at risk with the
Iranians because they're behind
Hezbollah Hamas and these attacks as
well and what I mean you put something
at risk something they don't want to
lose and that needs to be transmitted
through them and the president needs to
transmit it or either the Secretary of
State and what I mean what you put at
risk you pick up the phone and you call
the Iranians say the supreme leader is a
risk or their infrastructures at risk
they're using drones all of your drone
factories are at risk your Navy's at
risk in the area right now we have
incredible capability and capacity with
those two carrier strike groups an
amphibious ready group The batan and
also a an Ohio class bisted guided
missile submarine with over 150 tomland
attack missiles on it and each one of
those has a range of 1500 miles 1,000
pound Warheads on each you can virtually
destroy Iran with the Firepower we have
in that area right now and we need to
tell the Iranians knock it off this is
at risk and then we need to follow
through my concern Kaye right now is we
have all that capability but we don't
have the will to do it and that is being
proven day in and day out and most of
the attacks now are at Allis Airbase
over onethird of those attacks now have
gone in there and that's where the
predominant amount of Americans are
that's where the risk is and sooner or
later they're going to kill an American
and then what and the longer you wait to
respond the worse it's going to get it's
harder to put it back in the box and
that's where we're heading to it's
frightening and it's frightening to
think about what it would be like to
wake President Biden up at 2 a.m. I just
don't have faith at this moment in our
commander and chief General Keith
Kellogg thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else